the last time you were here i do
remember you saying to me
that
you told me you'd rather do anything
than have sex in your personal life now
you're really kind of
turned off yeah i think like when i last
saw you personally you were dating the
police officers very attractive nice
woman yes she's doing well in her life
and job and you know has data is dating
someone new so i feel happy for her and
i'm dating someone new as well oh don't
i know i listen you don't call me
personally but i look on tick tock to
see what you're up to yeah
and uh very attractive yes woman very
tattooed how do you feel about this
i have never dated a tattooed woman
before
this is my first tattoo she's got 23 we
counted them 23 tattoos including a huge
one on her neck
and her thighs and she's very very sexy
to me so in other words let's be frank
let's be frank
you now are ready
i'm back in action howard you are were
you shocked when you met her you met
online right yes tick tock which is
weird well i watched her tapes i watched
her little videos her tick tocks and
every time i saw her i would smile i'm
like this woman is like perfect look at
she's so
happy and enthusiastic and beautiful and
bright and she has a light coming from
her and you know she's always kind of i
don't know well how did you find her on
tick-tock i mean randomly literally
going through now i have never contacted
anyone on tick tock that i wanted to
date ever besides her i sent her a dm
and said
were you nervous no
no because i didn't know i thought maybe
we would just be friends i said you're
you're very beautiful i love your look
and 10 days later she wrote me back a
little video
like she was singing a song and going hi
hi you know so you're in love i'm in
love you know listen i i am and she's
really
kind and wonderful and i like the pace
that we're going at it's not like a
u-haul situation no marriage we're not
doing no we're not doing a third
marriage howard no no no that's it
enough no i promise you howard too
you're not good at marriage no
i would say it's not my best thing but
maybe she wants marriage with you you
might have to deal with that at some
point
maybe i don't know we'll we'll see how
we get there and what it feels like you
know she's not pressuring you she's not
pressuring me which is good because i
don't do well under pressure like that
no it only feels like a weight but that
hasn't happened so next time when we see
you you'll be married
exactly and robin you'll be the maid of
honor
absolutely she'll be a wonderful maid of
honor